okay another great week welcome welcome
everybody welcome to another another
week I hope you had a wonderful
joy-filled weekend
mine sadly was mired by the fact that
for some reason I'm a football fan a
Ravens fan even worse and of course they
lost to put a mildly they lost in the
divisional round of the playoffs and the
thing is I was emotionally devastated I
was tormented traumatized broken ruined
which is basically how I feel at the end
of every football season except for the
two where we went to the Super Bowl and
won but then there's this moment that
the next day and any sports fan I think
could probably relate to this there's
the neck there's a moment the next day
maybe two days later after the season is
over and it feels like you're waking up
from hip hypnosis or something and I
always think you know a couple days
later after I have a little bit distance
I think why do I care so much about this
again what why do I have emotional
capital invested in the outcome of a
game played between people I don't even
know like what differs how would my life
be improved
if my favorite team won a championship
in the sport that I like how is my life
damaged when they don't why does any of
this matter to me and I can't answer
those questions I really can't I don't
know why it matters except to say that I
think being a sports fan is a form of
psychosis I think it could be diagnosed
I'm sure eventually it will be diagnosed
in fact I'm sure eventually the you know
the are the the psychiatric industry
will come up with a with a pill they've
come up with a pill for everything else
so they'll come up with a pill to cure
sports fan itis and you know what when
they come up with that pill I will take
it because it's just it's not worth it
it really is I wish I didn't care about
sports I could you know I could get my
Sunday's back I could start I don't know
gardening or something I don't know it
figure out something to do with the time
but it's it's just better than sitting
there caring so much about this nonsense
all right
speaking of psychosis we have to begin
on a Monday with unfortunately not the
kind of story you want to
our week with but I think it's important
so there's this guy in Michigan
pedophile is gonna be spending the next
10 to 20 years in prison after being
caught with child pornography now in
court he offered two defenses of his
behavior and the defense's fortunately
were not successful but they are kind of
interesting
um one he said that child pornography is
protected under the First Amendment - he
claimed that he himself though he is a I
think 45 year old man he claimed that
he's really an 8 year old girl so let's
take a look at a report done by the
local ABC affiliate done in over in
Grand Rapids Michigan with this case
happened here's there's were there there
report on this watch joseph goldbrick
argued that his drawings and computer
images did not constitute child
pornography now during a recent court
appearance he even compared his felony
child porn convictions to the horrors of
Auschwitz our statements in a case that
was unique to say the least
Joseph goldbrick was arrested back in
2018 for child sexually abusive material
found on his home computer now that came
amid an investigation into a runaway 17
year old girl from Ohio during a search
of gold bricks home on Pine Avenue
Northwest in Grand Rapids police
recovered child pornography from his
computer goldbrick contends it was not
real child porn but rather computer
animated and Goldberg says he identifies
as an 8 year old girl
Kent County Assistant Prosecutor Dan
hammer says more than 50 elicit images
were on goldbricks computer
they included actual victims known to
police but that wasn't all
Jr okay so the judge was not convinced
by that excuse and he shouldn't be
obviously because it's insane but based
on the precedents in place the precedent
of accepting the self-identification of
a person who claims you know a man who
claims to be a female well we have to
accept that self-identification
in other words if you're going to accept
that a man can be a woman exactly on
what basis do you reject his claim to
being an 8 year old girl that's that's
the problem if you're gonna do the first
thing if you're gonna say yeah this
biological male is a woman in some
mysterious sense then why can't he in
the same sort of mysterious sense really
be an 8 year old girl or a 12 year old
boy or whatever he wants to be so we
know in this case according to left-wing
gender theory which is now mainstream
gender theory promoted by the media and
Hollywood in academia and everywhere
else corporations so we know that we
can't reject this scumbags claim to
being a female that part he's allowed to
have right we have no basis if he says
that he's a female then we have to just
give him that don't we the fact that
he's a creepy old bald dude is
irrelevant he says he's a female and so
he is that's that's the way it goes
what about age though well remember by
the way we've seen this before there was
that a few years ago there was that
50-plus year old man who left his family
left his left his wife and kid to live
as a six year old girl you may remember
maybe you've remembered you remember
that case maybe you've blocked it out of
your head probably a better thing to do
but on what basis do we reject their
claims to being young girls if we accept
the idea that a man can be a woman see
we can't say well as as sane and
reasonable people
we are response when a when a 45 year
old man says he's a 8 year old girl we
could say well he's just not he's he's
physically not an 8 year old girl in any
sense of the word so that claim is
nonsense we can reject it on that basis
it is just factually biologically
chronologically physically in every
sense untrue and therefore it's untrue
but the problem is that same argument
also disqualifies any man who claims to
be a woman because we could look at them
and see that they are biologically
physically chromosomally you know
hormonal II in every sense a male and so
therefore that's what they are it's just
not true that they're a woman but if
we're not if we can't do that if we
can't look at someone physically and
make these determinations based on
science and biology then again we're
left with the same problem how do we how
do we disqualify someone who says that
they're a child when they're really an
adult because we've already established
that physical and biological rate
realities are irrelevant and we can't
say well gender is fluid but age is not
first of all gender is not actually
fluid there's just two of them
biologically speaking there aren't any
others it is a binary system we just
pretend that it's it's not binary that
it's fluid so why can't we do the same
with age in fact here's the thing age
actually is fluid in a sense in the
sense that nobody stays one age forever
I'm a 33 year old man now I'm not gonna
be a 33 year old man two years from now
I'm still gonna be a man but I won't be
thirty-three anymore I wasn't a 12 year
old boy forever I was only that for one
year right so age does change more over
a man who says that he he feels like a
woman has no frame of reference he's
never been a woman and therefore he
doesn't know what what it's like to feel
like one and so whatever feelings he's
having he has no way of knowing if those
are actually woman feelings and so
therefore become
this circular logic where he says he is
a woman because he feels like one well
how does he know that he feels like one
because he is one right it's a circle it
doesn't make any sense
but with age at least an adult who
claims to feel like a child whatever
that means can at least say that he has
some frame of reference he was at one
point a child so he sort of knows what
that feels like
moreover we know that there are
psychological and neurological
conditions that cause adults to
essentially have the brains of the brain
of a child know that that is a thing
that happens there are people who are
severely mentally delayed and even
though their body is that of an adult
they have the mind of a child
so therefore claiming to be a child
stuck in an adult's body actually can
have some truth to it whereas claiming
to be a woman stuck in a man's body just
has no truth to it whatsoever now I
don't think that's the case for this
scumbag who by the way should be going
to prison for life not just for ten
years for twenty years but I'm just
trying to make the point here that trans
age actually has a better scientific
basis and is more justifiable than
transgenderism it's still BS it's still
bogus it's still nonsense it's still
it's still madness but if you're going
to accept transgenderism there just
isn't is no logical and coherent
argument for rejecting trans ageism
there just isn't whatever argument you
make against the claim that an adult can
identify as a child would apply would
even more so apply to the claims that a
man can be a woman so you have to choose
it's as simple as that and this is not a
slippery slope or slope argument because
I'm not talking about slopes you know
about one thing one thing leading to a
more extreme thing that's not what I'm
saying I'm not saying that
transgenderism is leading to or will
lead to the more extreme case of an
adult claiming to be a child what I'm
saying is that transgenderism
is already a more extreme thing than
trans ageism and trans racialism by the
way for that matter I'm saying that
those things are higher up on the slope
and if we're on this slippery slope into
into crazyville
you know you've got trans ageism and
trans racialism like somewhere around
here on the slope and then
transgenderism is like down here because
it makes less sense than these other
things over here or you know in fact
putting slopes aside entirely this is
really a question of categories there
are certain things about yourself that
you can change your hairstyle your
weight you can learn a new language your
personality can change and it does for
everybody to some extent these things
are in some sense fluid they change they
can be adjusted you can choose to make
changes to them but then there are other
things that you cannot choose to change
because they're simply facts about you
they just are your sex your race your
age my point is this if you're going to
extract anything from that second
category of unchangeable things and try
to put it into the first then everything
else in that category comes with it
because the logic that keeps one thing
in that category keeps everything there
and if we're abandoning that logic then
there is no basis anymore to keep
anything in that category and now we
have to say that that category doesn't
exist the category of things that you
can't change about yourself now simply
doesn't exist you can change everything
especially when it comes to sex because
in fact your sex is the thing that most
belongs in the second category it is the
most unchangeable thing about you it is
the Brutis of brute facts your age will
change on its own your race can be a mix
of many different things but your sex
just is if that
if that of all things is now relative
then so is everything else and that's
the problem here
so what the left will do because they
they they haven't they haven't even
really gotten to the point yet where
they're accepting transracial ism maybe
a little bit yeah I think we see
movement in that direction but they're
not there yet they certainly aren't
accepting trans ageism but they've
already made the arguments for it and
this is what we see with the left a lot
or they make they make a certain
argument because they're trying to
justify one particular thing but the
problem is that that argument also
justifies a whole bunch of other things
and it takes them a while to circle back
around and say oh yeah you know that
other stuff yeah maybe that stuff is
good too at first they'll always say no
no we're not trying to justify that
understand I don't know this is
different they can't tell you why it's
different they can't explain it but
they'll say that it is the same thing
with you know another obvious example is
with marriage they say marriage is not
between one man and one woman and
originally they said oh no you know
we're not trying to justify things like
polygamy now now we're at the point
where I think most leftist will say yeah
sure who cares polygamy is fine but at
first they claimed if you recall when we
when we were having this argument
especially in the lead-up to the Supreme
Court decision on gay marriage the claim
for most leftist was no now when I try
to judge polygamy no that's not that's
not the point of course every argument
you've made for getting rid of the idea
of one man one woman marriage would
apply to polygamists just as much even
more so actually that's another example
where polygamy is a little bit further
up on the slope not further down it just
took them a while to circle back around
the same thing is gonna happen with this
Tran with the trans stuff where they're
trans in everything they started with
gender
that is the most extreme thing to trans
of all the things to trans that's the
most extreme but they started with that
and now it's just a matter of circling
back around and saying yeah that - oh
sure you have that also alright before
we move on let's let's hear a word from
our friends over at Duke canon here's a
fact most resolutions don't last right
mostly because dramatic self-improvement
is really hard and that's why Duke
canons Supply Company wants you to
consider lowering your expectations this
year and this is see this is what I like
it's like let's be realistic
okay lower the expectations with the
moderate self-improvement box it's a one
step program to achieving a slightly
better version of yourself this is not a
total transformation folks it's just a
you know a slight improvement baby steps
this box is packed with over eighty
dollars of premium american-made
grooming goods designed to help you feel
look and smell just a little bit better
in 2020
usually this is 84 bucks you're getting
it for $50 though for only a limited
time and so you can you can improve
things like you'll have less stink right
where they've got the the trench warfare
antiperspirant and deodorant where you
get that clean sort of subtle scent of
fresh air and and maybe a little bit of
lumber as well a little bit of
lumberjack you can have better hair
they've got the news anchor two-in-one
hair wash and then you can also have the
press so you get rid of the bad send
then you add a little bit of the good
set with the big-ass brick of soap which
I have right now in my shower as I speak
this is a program that I think anyone
can follow because again it's not about
it's not about a 180 turn it's like
let's start with maybe I don't know 10
degrees complete the program and you'll
receive a certificate of completion
demonstrating your marginal commitment
to moderate self improvement and this is
something that everybody wants by the
way it's free shipping to the lower 48
states all products are tested by active
duty military and 5% of the net profits
are donated to causes benefiting
veterans and active-duty military do
Canon prides itself in making its
grooming goods work as hard as you do
they're champions of builders farmers
soldiers sledgehammers
teachers first responders holders of
doors and fixers of toilets and they
want you to feel right at home
and Duke cannon country visit Duke
cannon comm use the promo code Walsh for
15% off your entire order that's Duke
cannon comm from a code Walsh
all right Bernie Sanders sent out a
tweet that says the tweet the caption is
there are only 22 days until the Iowa
caucus it's time to get rolling can you
take a trip to help our campaign win in
the essential early states sign up here
and then so that's a okay
pretty normal caption but it's a caption
of a video of him Sanders pulling out of
the driveway of one of his three houses
and I don't just watch this clip
why I don't know if this is
self-deprecation if so then I respect it
but I can't quite figure out why Bernie
Sanders released a video of himself
charging out of his driveway bagging I
was driving swerving wildly and then and
then backing out of the driveway at full
speed without stopping to look both ways
like a stereotypical old person this is
the stuff of stand-up comedy routines
going back 40 years of how old people
back out of their driveways and then in
there now you have it Bernie Sanders 78
year old man however old he is doing
exactly that
that's you know back now that you saw
there was very little visibility because
it's all the cars parked on there on the
road there and he just charges right out
doesn't stop to look I don't whywould
I'm not sure what the point there is and
showing us that other than I guess just
embracing it and saying look I'm I am
very old that's true this is how I back
out of the driveway deal with it and if
that's his message and I respect it
alright so last week I don't remember
why this came up exactly but last week
we were talking about how so many people
in our culture today value their pets
over fellow human beings and one of the
emails I received in response to that
discussion inspired me to put up an
online poll and that poll has revealed
some disturbing findings so the email
from Trinity says hi Matt I agree with
everything you said on the show
regarding people valuing dogs more than
humans I asked many people what would
they choose a random person or their pet
if they were both found drowning
surprisingly everyone answered their pet
what do you think is the underlying
reason for this is it the lack of
religion and unclear morals so I thought
this is a good question so I stole the
question adjusted it a little bit I put
it on my Twitter I posed a version of
this and my question was very simple
your favorite pet and a grown man you
don't know are trapped in a burning
building you could only save one who do
you choose now as of this more
I haven't checked in a few hours but as
of this morning there were almost 30,000
votes tabulated out of that out of
30,000 votes 40% 40% said they would let
a human being burn to death
in favor of saving an animal 40% now you
might say this is not a scientific
result this was not a scientific polls a
Twitter poll it's not even it's not
exactly a random sample right these are
people who mostly follow me on Twitter
or so is there some bias there or
whatever and and that's true but listen
to this because this is kind of
remarkable I looked this up after the
fact I found that a psychologist
conducted a similar survey in a more
scientific setting to find out you know
whether people will put their pet above
the needs of a human and his results are
exactly the same so this psychologist
named Richard to Polsky surveyed people
and asked them in this scenario it's a
it's a it's a person and a dog and
they're both about to be hit by a bus
and you could only save one and again in
this case 40% this same exact percentage
40% said that they would save their dog
over a human what are the chances you
know that two surveys conducted
separately would coincidentally come to
the same conclusion in terms of the
percentages I think it's more likely
that this 40% the reason why we both
came to 40% is because that really is
representative 40% of people in this
country do put their pets lives above
human life and what makes this even more
depressing is that my followers skew
heav'nly of heavily in the direction of
conservative Christians so you know
maybe if you had just seen this poll
result from the psychologists you would
say oh you know well maybe that's a
whole bunch of liberal godless atheists
you know who denialists who don't value
human life at all and says no this is
this is not that this is this apparently
doesn't matter what your
ideology is or religion you know this is
there's the same tendency now as
expected in Topolsky study he found that
the forty percent figure dips
significantly when people are asked to
choose between their dog and somebody
they know so if it's a stranger then
yeah forty percent are saying screw that
guy let him get splattered by the bus
but if you say okay what if it's a and
in fact the number is still really high
if it's a distant cousin so it could be
a family member but if it's distant
cousin I think it was I don't know I
don't have it in front of me but it was
a high percentage of people said even in
that case see you later cousin now if
you get down to like a best friend
grandparent a best friend or grandparent
or maybe both if you're a grandparent is
your best friend in in that case the
vast majority people are gonna save the
best friend or the get grandpa but still
there still were a minority of people
according to this study small minority
but still they're there there's a
minority of people who said that they
would let their grandmother get run over
by a bus rather than their dog now this
speaks to something that I've been
talking about for years and it annoys
people whenever I talk about it and I
can already feel through the camera I
can feel people getting annoyed at me
right now as I speak it's a common
feeling for me but I'm gonna keep
talking about because I think it's I
think it's actually important I think
our in in this is really a kind of a
troubling trend it's it's not good to
have so many people who don't understand
that their pets life is not as valuable
as human life there is a problem this
culture of people failing to understand
that human life is more important and
more precious than animal life the pet
obsession has gotten to this
pathological state where it's turning
people into sociopaths who no longer
recognize the inherent value of human
life I don't know how else to describe
that I mean all these people at least my
Twitter's again the
it's not just that people were answering
the survey but they were justifying it
openly announcing and saying yeah sure
yeah I'd totally I'd let a person die
for the sake of my dog and it's like you
do realize that that's you you have the
moral insight of a psychopath right you
do realize that you couldn't possibly
justify that morally on any level you
realize that don't you I don't know it's
a it's not even a rhetorical question I
don't know if these people realize it or
not are they just are they just
embracing the fact that they're
Psychopaths
now look I'm not saying that having a
pet automatically does that to you okay
I'm not saying that every person who has
a pet is a psychopath yeah maybe you
could make an argument but no that's not
what I'm saying I'm saying that the
obsessive pet focused pet centered life
that some people lead has contributed to
has caused has fed this delusion that
animals are more not even as important
as people but more important and when
people go around calling their pets
their children and that sort of stuff it
seems like after a while some of them
really start to believe it
and I didn't put this poll up because
honestly I don't even want to know the
answer but I was tempted to ask what if
it was your dog in your child who do you
choose I'm betting you now I think it'd
be small minority but there are people
who would choose the dog we already know
from this psychologist that there are
definitely people who choose the dog
over the grandparent this also by the
way this is not and before we try to
make excuses and say oh this is natural
you know people this is how they are
with their dogs it's not natural this is
actually the opposite of natural this is
completely unnatural our natural
inclination is to is to prefer our own
species and every species is like this
your natural inclination is supposed to
be to prioritize your own
species we are all naturally species
issed and we should be that that is a
good prejudice to have every other
species has it I can guarantee you dogs
care more about other dogs lions care
more about other lions gorillas care
about care more about other gorillas
they are naturally inclined in that
direction
so if you're tempted to say well of
course people feel this way about their
pets that's how it's always been
no it's it no it's not of course it's
not how is always it's always been this
is a distinctly modern and Western
phenomenon phenomenon as I said last
week now to answer the question posed by
the person in the email saying you know
why is this happening why are so many
people now essentially psychopaths who
don't even understand that human life is
more important than animal life why do
we live in a country where so many
people would let a human being likely a
father and a husband burn alive in favor
of saving their stupid pets well here's
my theory to that and I'll give actually
I'll get my 30 second but I'd really
want to dwell on this isn't because I
know that it's it's a hypothetical and
you could say that all day long you
could say oh it's just a hypothetical
yeah it's a hypothetical but that
there's a point here it's a it's a it's
a thought experiment to try to figure
out what your priorities are so if you
you know if you're in the 40% think
about what you're saying you're saying
that you would let a conscious
self-aware human adult who is Mota's a
family and is most likely a husband and
a father you would let him burn alive a
absolutely torturous horrific death that
he will be fully aware of and you will
let his family be his children be
orphaned and you'll let his wife be
widowed for the sake of your dog my god
just and I want to believe that most
maybe you're just not thinking it
through I don't know really think about
that
um and then I had a lot of other people
saying oh you know we you can't really
answer this question it's a difficult
call it's one of those things you have
to be you don't know what you'll do in
the moment until you're there no I know
what I would do I could tell you right
now I have a cat and if that cat is
trapped at a burning building and
there's a human there
see you later cat that's I don't have to
think about it that's no hesitation not
even a second there would not be one
second of me going mmm you know I've got
the guy there is trapped and then I've
got the cat there wouldn't be one second
of me going should I get the cat and
then the guy looks at me and guilt trips
me and no that wouldn't happen I just
I'm going right for the guy so why you
know why is it why do people put their
pets above they're above humans I think
it comes down to selfishness and when
you think of it that way it's a lot less
mysterious once you start to realize
that most of the bad stuff you know in
life most of the bad things we do most
of our bad priorities it always comes
down to selfishness in the end because
this pet obsession and again when I say
obsession I mean obsession I'm not
talking about if you have a pet and you
love your pet but the love you have for
your pet is in a proper perspective and
it's proportionate and you obviously put
humans above your pet and you put your
family above your pet and you put
strangers but you know if you're in that
category then then go in peace god be
with you I have no problem with you I am
also a pet owner so I'm you know we're
we're on the same page right I'm talking
about the wackadoodles who openly
announced that they would save their cat
or dog and let a human being burned to
death that's what I'm talking about and
for those people I think it is
selfishness which is very different from
normal sort of animal lovers meaning the
people in the first camp people who love
animals but not more than they love
people and people like that people who
have a very you know have a great
passion for animals and our animal
lovers but but still it's all in
proportion and they would never value
over those people I admire because I
think you know that comes from from a in
a an abiding and abounding just
compassion for all living things and and
I think that's great right but the
people who put the animals above other
people I think for them it is a sort of
a selfishness and and I think the reason
is you know what is it that they like
about the pet well it's because the pet
makes them feel good the way people talk
about dogs I know the dog worships the
ground you walk on they're so excited
when you come home it's like yeah all
that is fine now personally I don't need
to be worshipped every second of the day
it's a little bit much honestly to have
a dog following me around all hours of
the day worshiping me a little bit much
don't really need that I need a little
space but it could be nice sometimes I
suppose but that's really what people
love about their pets and then they'll
say things like Oh a pet will never
betray you like a person will pet will
never lie to you like a personal what
they're really saying is you know I want
to be in a relationship with someone
where it's all about me and I am getting
nothing but but it's it I'm getting
nothing but but pleasure out of it and I
never have to deal with any you know the
other person never sort of intrudes
their own personality on me I never have
to do you know I never have to do
anything like forgive that's what
they're saying that's why they prefer
animals over humans because the
relationship you can have with a human
being is much richer and much deeper and
much more meaningful as anybody who's
ever had a real relationship with
another person knows but yeah it is a
person and so they have their own
personality they have their own goals
they have their own priorities
they have moral weaknesses they are
gonna do things sometimes like like lie
to you they might betray you these that
you know so then you need to forgive
them and it takes more work on your end
and I think there are a lot of people
who are so weak and so selfish and so
pathetic that they don't want to do that
work for another person they just want
it
you know they'll substitute a person for
a dog and enough to worry about any of
that and the dog will just worship then
we'll be all about them and you know the
dogs always there they can keep the dog
at home when they go to work they come
home the dog is there they can always
just put the dog where they want the dog
but it's always really just about them
in the end I also think there's the
Disney effect I think a lot of adults
still think they're in a Disney movie
and I guess because I grew up watching
this and so they ascribe noble
intentions to their pets they talk about
their pets as if their pets are virtuous
saintly creatures you know they really
do ascribe virtuous motives to their
pets but you notice it never goes on the
other end like they would never accuse
their dog of knowingly stealing you know
they would never think that their dog
should be held morally responsible for
stealing something from the counter
maybe you know stealing some some some
food from the counter even if their dog
goes and bites someone they immediately
make any excuse they oh it's just that
he's a dog you know he doesn't know any
better
so when it comes to something bad their
dog doesn't deserve any moral guilt but
on the other hand with the good stuff
it's oh no he's loyal he's loving he's
so what they've made the dog out to be
this morally perfect angelic creature
which of course is insane and in reality
with animals most of what they do is
instinctive you know they do it because
they've been programmed that way
biologically by nature most of the love
they show to you it's only because you
feed them and and if you stop feeding
them they'd probably eat you instead
that's the thing you know it's and so
that's that's the that's really the test
you say your dog loves you I mean maybe
there's a certain emotional sense of
that where he does have some affection
for you but if you stop feeding your dog
he'll eat you and then you just will
your kids probably won't but your dog
will because he's a dog and that's fine
you know it's fine for dogs to be dogs
but let's just
let's just keep it in let's just keep it
in perspective is all I'm trying to say
all right let's go to emails Matt wall
show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from Carlos says Matt
great show great columns great
everything etc on Twitter you were
discussing thinkers who have different
world view world views from your own you
gave a favorable mention to Sam Harris
and even said you found his argument
against free will persuasive can you
elaborate on that I have to say I was
shocked to read this from you given that
you've so often defended free will yeah
well we were talking about that on
Twitter and I do appreciate Sam Harris
I've read many of his books I didn't say
and he wrote a book against you know
like arguing against the concept of free
will pretty short little book and I
think it's worth reading now I didn't
say that his argument against free will
was persuasive let alone did I say that
I was persuaded by it
so I didn't say that I read his book and
said you know what there is no free will
I said it was it was a more formidable
argument that he presented than I
expected
and and part of my point here is that we
have to be willing to admit when
somebody makes a formidable ie credible
intelligent plausible argument that we
disagree with because I think if we've
never encountered a formidable argument
that we disagree with that's a pretty
good indication that we're living in a
bubble so I thought he made a pretty
good case for his view but I still
disagree with his conclusion let me tell
you why I disagree first of all and then
I'll get to the formidable aspect of his
argument I disagree with anybody
claiming that free will doesn't exist
and this is determinism if you want the
fancy ism name for this view I disagree
because as far as I can tell you just
can't get around a simple fact and that
simple fact is that like I am choosing
to do this right now okay
raising the mug up and down which by the
way you can get these the daily wire
store I'm
to do this I could not be doing this I
could be doing any number of other
things rather than doing this I could go
downstairs and make a grilled cheese
sandwich
I could go jump in a lake I could go in
a killing spree
I could I could do all of those things
but instead I'm sitting here right now
raising my mug up and down like an idiot
that's a choice that I'm making and when
I say that I could be doing those things
what I mean is
those are theoretical options available
to me and there is nothing actively
physically preventing me from doing them
so I could do them and if I could and
you know I can do anything within the
laws of physics and if I can do anything
theoretically within the laws of physics
then I have free will at least that's
what I mean when I talk about freewill
now here's an example of true
determinism computers so I could build a
fancy robot well I couldn't build a
fancy row because I'm stupid but a smart
person could build a fancy robot that
can you know walk across the room pour a
cup of coffee bring it back to you
something really impressive like that
but that's programmed the robot has no
choice literally no choice it could
malfunction and go and do something else
but again that's not a choice that's
just a malfunction it can't choose to do
something else and with all due respect
to terminator and the matrix it couldn't
actually choose to go out and kill
people or enslave mankind or do any of
that stuff it can only do what it's
programmed to do or else it can break
those are kind of the two possibilities
my computer could not even theoretically
become a Buddhist I could theoretically
become a Buddhist that's an option open
to me I could do it because I have I
have free will the only reason I'm not a
Buddhist right now is because I haven't
chosen to be one so I think free will
stands but here's the formidable aspect
of Harris's argument and I'm summarizing
it very briefly try not to make a straw
man out of it so if I do make a straw
man out of it that's that's
unintentional but I think his point is
basically this
so take a murderer for example okay
that murderer chose to be a murderer I
would say chose to shoot up the movie
theater and you would say that well he
chose to do that and you chose not to do
that and that's the reason you're not a
murderer and he is but Harris says hold
on a second
wait a minute what if you had the exact
same genes as that guy not like pants
but genes genetics well if you had the
exact same genes and the same
psychological makeup and the same mental
illnesses if he hasn't and the same
family background and the same childhood
traumas and every other thing that's
happened to that guy that he didn't
choose let's say all of that happened to
you also can you be so sure in that case
that you wouldn't also be a mass
murderer and the answer we have to admit
is no you know we can't be so sure in
fact probably we would be if we were in
the exact same situation as that guy
exact same from birth everything is
exactly the same you'd probably do the
same thing in fact we would probably be
that guy I mean then we would
essentially be him and we probably do
everything that he does another example
I think maybe even a better example
would be easier to have will be suicide
bomber and we know with a suicide bomber
we could take even genetics and stuff
out of it and let's just say that you
know you grew up in Iraq and you were
indoctrinated into militant Islam every
day of your life from birth and you were
told every day of your life from birth
that you know if you become a martyr
you'll get 72 virgins and and you had
all that same conditioning for years and
years and years and years and years
would you become a suicide bomber too
probably
and you know and that's a good point
that he raises and I think
we have to grapple with it it's not a
Polly thing you can just gloss over it's
a point that we niña the Harris Britain
makes goes back to this theme in his
book where this is like this is
something we want to gloss over because
it makes us uncomfortable and we start
to feel the the foundations of our
justice system sort of begin to collapse
around us where if now we're saying that
like we would probably do all of the bad
things that bad people have done if we
were in their same exact situation like
then what basis do we have to even put
them in jail and all these questions
come rushing in and it's very disturbing
but here's my response what Harris is
talking about these factors that he's
talking about are influences they are
things that can influence you in one
direction or another and they may be
very strong influences very strong no
brainwashing from birth is a
indoctrination from birth into a certain
worldview doesn't have to be Milton
Islam could be anything but being
indoctrinated into it from birth is a
very very strong influence it is very
hard to you know be born into a certain
worldview a certain way of thinking and
to break out of that it is very hard to
do most people can't and the only way
that you know if you can as if you've
done it if you have never have now
hopefully you didn't you didn't need to
because you were and you were sort of
indoctrinated quote-unquote into the
right way of thinking but if you've
never had to make that effort of
breaking out of that then you don't
really know if you could or not you
probably you can't because most people
can but my point is you still have a
choice you aren't literally programmed
you could theoretically do something
else and that's all I mean by free will
which is why I say that free will still
stands right you take somebody in the
inner city someone born you know with no
father in the home born in in in the in
the in the projects nothing but bad
influences all around nothing but crime
and drugs all around
terrible school system all of that right
and then they go and become a drug
dealer and Harris would say well if you
were in that exact same situation
wouldn't you also be a drug dealer
probably yes probably but that doesn't
mean they don't actually have a choice
they do have a choice the choice is
still there you could choose something
else and we know that one way we know
that is that some people do choose you
know there are a lot of people who are
grown who are born into terrible
situations frankly end up being terrible
people and that's that's the horrible
thing about it just like there are a lot
of people who you know suffer all kinds
of trauma as children and then go on and
become sexual abusers and pedophiles I
think if you look at most pedophiles you
look at their family background you're
gonna find that a lot of horrible things
happen to them when they were kids but
that doesn't mean there is still a
choice you can break out of that and we
know there are plenty of people who are
born in these horrible situations
whether they're born you know into
militant Islam and they're trying to
people trying to condition them and
condition them into being suicide
bombers or they're born into a situation
where a lot of people become drug
dealers there are people born in those
situations who do break out of that and
make better choices and prove and it
takes a whole lot of courage and guts
and and everything more than probably I
have or you have but it is possible
let's look at another example let's say
if someone puts a gun to your head let's
say that you're sitting at a desk
there's a button on the desk and if you
press that button it's gonna it's gonna
set off an explosion across town that
kills a thousand people and let's say
someone puts someone literally puts a
gun to your head and says press that
button actual gun to the head now I
guess Sam Harris would say your free
will has been taken from you well you
never had free will to begin with but
you know according to him but you have
no choice he would say you have a gun to
your head and on one level it makes
sense yeah there's a gun to your head
what choice do you have
but my point is you actually do have a
choice the gun represents a very very
very very strong influence in one
direction but you could still choose not
to press it the
is gonna be a horrible consequence for
you you're gonna be killed probably but
you could make that choice that choice
is still available to you it is still a
theoretical option it may take a lot of
courage a lot of guts but you could do
it and so you have free will and so
really all of these things that Harris
brings up even though they're they're
good things to consider
and it's interesting to talk about them
they actually have nothing to do with
freewill at all because they they have
they have no bearing on the fact that we
can still make whatever choice we want
to make you know it is true and I've
talked about it myself that's um
most of the choices we make in life are
determined by desire and opportunity in
other words most of the things you've
done in your life you've done them good
or bad you've done them because you
wanted to number one and number two
because you had the opportunity to do it
and by opportunity I mean not just the
physical opportunity to do it but also a
chance to do it without there being in
your mind horrible consequences for it
so good or bad let's just focus on the
bad for a minute every sin you've
committed every bad thing you've done
big or small thing why did you do it you
did it because you wanted to and because
you had the chance to and that really is
insane for the good stuff and that
really does seemingly determine most of
the things that we do in life and in
fact most of the times when you decline
to do a bad thing and maybe you want to
give yourself moral credit for it and
say oh I didn't do that because it's
wrong but really no that's not really
the reason you didn't do it the real
reason you didn't do it is because
probably because you didn't want to like
I went into a store recently kind of a
mom-and-pop shop and I was looking
around and whoever was supposed to be
the cash register was in the back for
like 10 minutes store was unattended
there were no cameras and I thought to
myself anyone could just walk in here
and steal whatever they want I could
have stolen whatever I wanted I didn't
steal anything
why didn't I steal something I had the
opportunity white a nice
is it because stealing is wrong well
stealing is wrong but that's not why I
didn't do it I didn't do it because I
didn't want to I just had no desire to
steal ID if that's not something I want
to do I don't want to steal no desire
didn't even cross my mind across my mind
has an option for someone else and I was
hoping the guy would come out soon so
that wouldn't happen now what if I was
in that store same situation I got all
the opportunity in the world but I
really really really want to steal maybe
I'm a kleptomaniac maybe I've just been
raised that stealing is okay maybe I
have a you know I've fallen on hard
times and whatever like what if I really
had that strong desire what I have
stolen I don't know maybe you know I
think in order to know if we are
essentially slaves to opportunity and
desire in our life we just have to look
and see you know how many occasions have
there been in my life when I've really
wanted to do something bad and I've
really had the chance to do it without
there being any consequence and I didn't
do it and I think if we do an honest
assessment and we realize that you know
pretty much every time I want to do
something and I have the chance to do it
I do it if that's the case for us then
that means that that's that's that's
pretty much a hundred percent
confirmation that if you were in the
situation of the drug dealer or the bank
robber or the suicide bomber you do be
doing that stuff too but but opportunity
and desire often do determine our
actions as human beings but they don't
have to you can overcome that I mean you
can have the desire to do something bad
and the opportunity and not do it just
like you could do something good even
though you really don't want to do the
good thing and it's a big hassle to do
it and you could still do it anyway most
people don't act that way because most
people lack virtue and lack courage and
strength I'm one of them that doesn't
mean it has to be that way you can
overcome that and that's that's the
beauty
of free will that's what it means to be
free you know and and and so that it
that's really the point I think what
what Harris is really getting at is that
we are weak selfish people and on that
point I have I have no disagreement and
he's also making the point that hey you
know you're a weak selfish person
and so maybe slow your roll a little bit
you know and in in feeling superior to
all these other people that have done
bad things because you probably do the
same thing you like to claim you
wouldn't but you probably would and on
that point I agree it's a good point but
I just I wish he could make that point
without bringing freewill into it
because you know freewill is also the
thing that is is is that is the it's
freedom I mean it's also the the escape
offered to people in these horrible
situations what about what about the kid
who is brought up in a situation where
most people become drug dealers don't we
want to say to him look you don't have
to do this you can make a better choice
you don't have to be a slave to this you
can do something better
Sam Harris seems to be saying and anyone
who's a determinist is basically saying
no there's no point of even give even
I've even relaying that message to that
kid because he has no choice and I think
that's a horrible horrible mistake
alright um so that's freewill and I also
chose it was my free will to spend 30
minutes babbling about that so there you
go we all make choices that was mine and
I think we'll leave it here thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]